so a woman might think that she has low
libido when really she just doesn't want
to have sex with her partner because
there's years of unresolved issues and
unspoken conversations that have built
up this wall between them so it's not
that she physically you know has a low
libido diagnosis it's that no she
actually doesn't want to have sex with
him until these issues can get cleared
if women have this disconnect with their
vaginas through again through trauma or
like a lack of physicality or bad sexual
experiences then they're feeling a
dissociation so what you just said about
that bed-shaking
life-changing ecstasy inducing
hours-long
type sex that's what i'm trying to show
people is possible for everyone and so
if they've had these experiences of
really short-lived or disappointing
intimacy that that can be totally
different and totally taped
[Music]
that was kim anami a holistic sex and
relationship coach who is here to infuse
more passion into your life in bed her
work is a spiritual blend of over two
decades of tantra taoism transpersonal
psychology philosophy and growth
accelerating practices if you're looking
to deepen your connection your intimacy
energy your pleasure and creativity then
this is the episode for you this episode
contains such life-changing information
that you do not want to miss so buckle
up and be sure to get your partner to
listen in on this one too because the
information this episode will greatly
benefit you both and if after listening
to this episode you want more i am
really excited to announce that right as
this episode launches kim's signature
course vaginal kung fu is returning this
february open registration is from
january 19th to february 5th it's an
eight-week virtual salon to strengthen
and tone the vagina and enhance and
increase your orgasms if you're thinking
why would i need to strengthen my vagina
well you'll learn all about why in this
episode but also if a woman is
disconnected from her sexuality in her
vagina she is operating at a massive
disadvantage you can't tune into your
sexual energy and sexual pleasure if you
have a numb under-functioning vagina
kim believes that every woman should be
able to shoot ping-pong balls from her
vagina i know you might be confused
right now but keep listening and you'll
know what i mean
i personally have experienced massive
benefits from kim's advice so i'm also
going to be taking this course i hope
you'll join me
link to check out the courses in the
show notes and description box below and
if you're tuning into this episode after
open registration don't worry kim has
more courses coming up throughout the
year including the well [ __ ] woman the
coming together couple salon the sexy
mama salon and sexual mastery for men
all right are you ready let's get into
this episode all right
ah thank you so much kim for being here
i am
so excited for this conversation and
actually
since years ago when i learned about you
i have always thought
what i would give to sit on a couch with
kim and ami and just have a conversation
with you
so i'm really pumped about this
conversation
i'm really excited as well i've love
your work and your commitment and how
creative you are and we have a virtual
couch instead
we do we do
also i want to say too to preface that
i'm like a little bit nervous to get
into this conversation because i've
never talked so openly
about this topic but i'm also really
excited because it's such important
information
okay so before
before i dive in with like all those
questions i want to ask you i think it
would be good to preface
and just kind of set the groundwork for
people who are learning about you
through this conversation and they might
be like what the heck is this woman
about like shooting ping pongs out of
your vagina carrying surfboards
weightlifting with your vagina um all
this type of thing so my first question
is you talk a lot about how
it's a worldwide problem that so many
women are underfucked
can you just elaborate a little bit on
that
right so the whole basis of my work is
the idea that sexual energy is life
force energy this is the energy that
creates new life and if we're not
creating babies with that energy then
it's up to us to really learn how to
tune into it
and channel it as the creative
rejuvenating and healing power that it
really is and so the problem is is what
we're typically taught you know all over
the world about sex maybe not the case
in some indigenous cultures they might
have a more primal intuitive connection
to their sexuality but in most of the
civilized world is that there's so much
taboo and shame and trauma that's
overlaid on top of our sexual expression
is that most people have a very
distorted and traumatic relationship to
their sexuality if not literal trauma
that they've experienced in their
lifetimes and so the idea that it's this
healing potent
revitalizing force that we can use as a
creative energy in our lives is really
foreign to most people although when i
start talking about it they often get
this
intuitive resonance like yeah
that's what i've always felt but there's
been no framework to articulate that you
know the dominant messaging of the
culture is very much the opposite and so
my work then is all about the notion
that if you tune into this sexual energy
and this power that it will then
transform your entire life this is the
creative and birthing power of the
universe right we are the channels for
that especially as women and so when a
woman really begins to inhabit and own
and wear
that powerful
ecstatic life force energy she becomes a
force of nature she becomes unstoppable
she becomes what i call a well-fucked
woman which is someone who really owns
and radiates this beauty and sensuality
that is born out of her sexual energy
right this is the natural state that we
all ought to live in it's our natural
free energy source the best the biggest
free energy source we have in the
universe and we have it literally at our
fingertips and yet for so many people i
can feel like it's
miles and miles and miles and bodies
away from them
yeah i when i learned about you i was so
i was so compelled to just keep digging
because you went into exactly that that
it transforms every area of your life
and it's not just sex it really
transforms a lot of just how you go
about living your life and success and
happiness and joy and i kind of want to
share a little bit with you about my
personal story
basically the way i learned about you is
that i was had just given birth to my
second child
and um so i was in that postpartum
uh breastfeeding phase lower libido you
know just in that like taking care of
multiple kids way different than before
we had children and a friend of mine
came over and we had been friends for a
while but something about her just
seemed different when she came over to
my house that night and i didn't notice
the last few times i had seen her my
husband was at work she came over to
like make dinner with me and i'm like
wow sarah you are just looking extra
sexy and vibrant and just beautiful
lately like what is going on your lips
are extra plumped your hair looks
vivacious like you just look so sexy
lately like what is going on and she
leaned in and she's like i'm having
incredible sex
i'm like what like i was just so
taken aback by that i had never
considered that
notion like you're saying that it
extends to other areas of your life and
she told me that she had taken a course
from this woman named kim anami and i
didn't know who you were and she just
started telling me all about it as we're
chopping tomatoes and making salad and
i'm just like tell me more like it just
completely shook me
and that was a pivotal moment for me
because i started to learn about your
work and what you what you share about
and it completely transformed our sex
life even amongst that like incredibly
often difficult time to navigate within
your sex life it completely
changed everything for us and
and yeah that's how i learned about you
so it com i completely resonate with
everything you're saying about how
how it changes everything in your life
and and the dogma and kind of the
what we're taught in our life about sex
growing up
sex kind of is like told that it's for
men right like that it's like oh women
women you know well you'll enjoy it but
like it's mainly for men that's kind of
like my
the way that i was taught at least a
little bit
um and that you'll enjoy it but it's and
so i think that's what's so pivotal
about the work that you do just
expressing how that energy with inside
of you
yeah definitely i love that you actually
met a well-fucked woman and saw that
whole concept in real time right that
she was different and changed and
something was different about her you
know a different kind of radiance or
jeunesse aqua which is yeah sourced from
orgasms
so
um
yeah i mean like in terms of the male
female staff i do think that men are
given more permission to be overtly
sexual and there is that messaging that
women almost need to be coerced right to
to have sex right and that one of the
biggest archetypes that exists is
madonna horror right women are either
[ __ ] or they're virgins and there
doesn't really exist this happy medium
where women can be healthy voracious
empowered sexual beings and that's the
middle ground that i teach that's really
the core of my work right is that yes
you can be a woman who loves sex and is
very sensual wants sex but it doesn't
mean that you have to take on this other
programming of you know the horror
you know archetype or there's that
really good girl archetype like you know
the woman has to be talked into it or
coerced or manipulated into having sex
right or like you said almost like a
duty or obligation to please the man
like that's another kind of ideology and
so this is where in my work i really
encourage people to examine just like
you said these ideologies and beliefs
that they've taken on right that may not
actually be their truth but they've been
superimposed upon them by the culture at
large by their family of origin by their
religious upbringing by the media right
like it's the same thing in the media
you see sex everywhere it's selling
everything from toilets to toothbrushes
but you're not really allowed to have it
and enjoy it right it's this again this
dichotomy and so it's no wonder that
people have this chasm
of
disconnect and dissociation within
themselves when there's so much
conflicting messaging going on and then
you add on top of that if they've had
any kind of trauma like sexual abuse
growing up or assault or violation then
unless they've actually cleared that and
that's again part of what i do with
people is clear that those blockages and
rewire those neural pathways away from
trauma and into pleasure then they
aren't going to fully reclaim that state
and part of
what i tell everyone is that everyone
can this is the anami guarantee is that
every woman can be having a high libido
a salacious sex drive multiple vaginal
g-spot cervical ejaculating orgasms
every woman indeed can shoot ping-pong
balls from her vagina every man can
learn how to have sex for eight hours at
a time and separate orgasm from
ejaculation all of these things are
possible for every single person and
it's just a matter of digging in and
doing that work to remove these
blockages clear the space and come back
to our natural state which is as sensual
beautiful radiant beings we all have
that capacity every single person i
guarantee it that's like such
encouraging information and i think i
have a lot of mothers especially
listening who might be like yeah like
resonating with what you're saying and
they're like but how do i get there
because i'm so busy and i have this long
list of zoos and i have all the kids and
how are we gonna make our sex life you
know spontaneous when we have like
however many kids and um what advice do
you have i guess to start that work of
healing and to get to a place where you
are at a constant simmer as you talk
about which i'm sure we'll get into um
so that you're wanting sex with your
partner all day long or maybe just
consistently
well i think a big part of it is like in
the work that i do in my online courses
i call them savat or salons is looking
at these blockages like these ideas and
beliefs that we've taken on to see okay
is that really my truth or have i taken
that on like for example the thing that
you said right do men want or need sex
more than women is that really true
if i looked in my heart of hearts do i
really believe that or is that just an
idea that i've taken on that's been
permeated throughout the culture
if people have any kinds of sexual
trauma that's never been addressed
therapeutically and they've never healed
that all of these things show up in the
body right so a woman might think that
she has low libido when really she just
doesn't want to have sex with her
partner because there's years of
unresolved issues and unspoken
conversations that have built up this
wall between them so it's not that she
physically you know has a low libido
diagnosis it's that no she actually
doesn't want to have sex with him until
these issues can get cleared right the
same thing could apply to a lack of
lubrication or painful intercourse these
are the vaginas messages saying hey stop
i need you to deal with this stuff
before i want to go any further so it's
you know in the allopathic regime we're
really encouraged to dominate the body
right silence the body don't listen to
its messages override them and in my
work it's like no the body is all wise
and all we need to do is listen to it
but that involves a deeper psycho
spiritual conversation with the inner
self with our you know with our past
with our higher self to figure out well
why is the body saying this and how can
i get through this so one of the big
tenants in my work is radical honesty
right so having really honest
conversations with yourself with your
partner
to clear away any of that residue that's
built up over the years right people
shove things under the proverbial carpet
and after a while you have this these
massive piles in your room that you have
to jump over all these things that
you've stuffed under the carpet right
and so my work is like let's lift up the
carpet and one by one let's pull out all
of those things and as we do we will
notice the shift in the energy between
us because we've built walls now and
this is a process of taking down those
walls creating that intimacy and trust
again where we've probably moved away
from it
and then opening up
and so the true
power of sexuality as this
transformative rebirthing
ecstatic experience comes through having
the ability to really open and trust and
surrender both to ourselves and with our
partners and if we don't have that we
could be having what i call junk food
sex which is just bust out an orgasm
have a stress relief put you to sleep
kind of orgasm whether you're on your
own or with a partner versus really
opening and truly truly surrendering to
this cataclysmic you know unknown and
that's where we hit the gold of what i
call gourmet sex which is the kind of
sex that really changes your life
and the big barometric question i ask
people is does your sex life make you
feel rejuvenated energized transformed
and like it changed your life and if it
doesn't that means you're doing it wrong
and that's not a judgment as much to say
that there's a way of having sex that
gives you energy and feeds you and
becomes a power source or it actually
depletes you which is epitomized by the
guy who busts out an orgasm and then
passes out right like that's how
depleted the guy is
so you know the proof is in the pudding
yes everything you're saying is so on
point and especially from my own
personal experience
it was such a mind shift for me just
realizing like how important and
integral this is and just
reading the stuff honestly any anyone
listening just subscribe to your email
list and get your weekly emails and it
pumps you up i feel like so much of it
is in the mind and when you learn um the
true power of opening up that way and
the tools on how to help you and your
partner truly trust each other like you
said the more you trust each other and
open up then you can actually open up
during sex and have amazing sex and for
me back when i learned about you it was
just oh we have 20 minutes the baby's
asleep we got to hurry up type of thing
just get it done and it didn't it just
felt like a chore you know and then once
you learned like oh this is actually the
most beautiful and fulfilling and
enriching thing and it's so helpful for
our relationship and we flourish and
thrive
like through that that was integral and
but like you said it's all encompassing
on having to
be open with your partner and get rid of
all that gunk so that you truly trust
your partner and that's some really
powerful information you share as well
so can you talk a little bit about the
connection between
what men really need and what women
really need like from each other
connecting that emotional piece
i think that you know one of the things
that there was a quote
somewhere i'm trying to remember like
the sexiest thing that a man can do is
exactly what he says he's gonna do so
i'd say that it's this idea of integrity
and follow through keeping your word as
a man and by doing that you're really
embodying that archetype of like strong
pillar
power right that a woman can fall into
because one of the catchphrases that i
use is if i fall will you catch me and
that's the question that women are
perpetually asking men if i fall will
you catch me if i surrender if i open
myself emotionally sexually and you know
totally let go
in this cataclysm of of ecstasy will you
hold that space for me or will you drop
me like a hop data kind of thing so that
idea that women are testing man yeah
[ __ ] right we are we're always wanting
to see like are you going to hold that
space or are you going to drop me so
that's i think a really important thing
for men to continually reinforce for
women and that's keeping your word if
you say you're going to even take out
the garbage if you say you're going to
have a sex date if you say you're going
to bring her to an orgasm like follow
through on everything
and then for women i'd say that the
sexiest thing that she can give to her
partner is surrender this complete trust
and abandonment and openness that she's
just like take me i'm yours that is the
biggest surrender turn on for a man and
this reinforcement that he is worthy of
that surrender so obviously there's a
give and take in that in those in that
circular relationship of like he has to
be worthy of that for her to feel like
she'll surrender but that's the
continual work for the two people to do
with each other is that the woman is
really practicing opening and
surrendering and the man is really
reinforcing that he's worthy of that
surrender he's worthy of that trust yes
oh that's so beautifully said i also
think in in addition to that
things that you talk about how women
take longer to warm up and just learning
like practical tools i'm not expecting
women to just be ready let's go it's all
over in 20 10 minutes kind of thing and
learning that type of information on the
importance of generosity to your partner
which will in turn bring generosity back
together because then the woman is more
warmed up and the woman will be super
excited and wanting to like please the
partner as well
that was really pivotal for us as well
in in addition to everything you just
said
there's an old taoist expression it says
that men are like fire they are quick to
ignite and quick to extinguish and women
are like water they're slow to boil but
they keep on boiling and so the work for
men is to really cultivate their stamina
so that they have full control over
their orgasm they can go for at least an
hour without pausing or having an orgasm
and you know because a lot of women take
that long to reach orgasm and at least
the deeper vaginal orgasms and then for
women it's about cultivating that simmer
so instead of going from ice to boiling
they're already hovering and living in
this simmer zone of being in touch with
their sexual sexuality and their sensual
energy and
flowing in that space they're already
living in this place of perpetual
relationship and sensuality with the
world and themselves and their partner
and so it's an easy move to just to
slide into sexuality so obviously these
things are cultivated over time where
the man practices and does work to make
sure that he is in that realm of uber
stamina and the woman is also doing
things so that she's in that place of
living open and sensual and free rather
than shut down and closed and so when a
couple is coming into it from that space
if the woman is shut down and the man is
having really quick orgasms they're
never going to be sexually fulfilled
right he might think that he is but he's
really not and he's going to have this
massive guilt because he knows he didn't
go the distance or even remotely go the
distance with his partner and she's
going to feel resentful and let down and
probably will avoid having sex with him
right if she's got a two-pump chomp like
a perpetual premature ejaculator who's
not doing anything to work on that then
she's gonna avoid sex and she won't know
why she'll probably think she has a low
libido or she's tired from the kids but
really it's because he comes in three
minutes every time and she's like look
i'm not your receptacle i've got other
things to do that are more fulfilling
like laundry than do that again right
and so this is
that unspoken dialogue that they're
probably not even conscious of right
like unless you bring these things out
into a conversation
she's just probably like i said think
she has a low libido you know and he's
thinking oh she never wants to have sex
with me anymore it's not like it used to
be in the relationship it's like no she
probably just got tired
of you never improving that right and
she's like look you know
whatever i don't have you know even the
three minutes it would take for us to
have sex i'd rather go bake some cookies
totally and i totally see how it could
be subconscious because you're like eh i
might just not like sex that much and
not even realizing what the potential
could be because you think that's what
sex is and really it could be this like
bed shaking world shattering like
gourmet long sex but just because he
isn't able to get there not putting it
all on him obviously like you said it's
both inner work on both people but how
can men because you said i remember i've
seen you say in a video before that it's
like such a problem that so many men
uh have
that early ejaculation problem so how
what tools can they do to help extend
that breathing number one is breathing
and most i mean i think the stats are 75
percent of men ejaculate within three
minutes of intercourse it's it's real
that's insane it is it's dizzy it's so
hard to believe
it is and it isn't like if you talk to
any woman about her experience you know
she's probably going to be like yep
that's right wow and that's why i think
a lot of women can take it or leave it
when it comes to sex because they're
just like why would i bother
and a lot of what i do is showing people
what they don't know right you don't
know what you don't know so what you
just said about that bed shaking
life-changing ecstasy inducing
hours-long orgasm type sex that's what
i'm trying to show people is possible
for everyone and so if they've had these
experiences of really short-lived or
disappointing
intimacy that that can be totally
different and totally changed so for men
yeah i'd say the number one most
important thing for men to work on is
their stamina and i would say that the
absolute minimum for a man is to have
one hour where he's able to have
intercourse and not ejaculate so that
he's in full control of his ejaculation
so the way to get there is conscious
breathing most men when they're
approaching and women too but especially
men when they're approaching orgasm they
tend to hold their breath
breathe really shallow tighten up the
body this like
great like kind of experience and then
they pass out right i'm done yeah we all
know that face right every woman is like
yeah i know that face and that clench
you know and so the opposite is what to
do is to really breathe deep like i
recommend a four count inhale and a four
count exhale like a yoga vinyasa flow
breath right and especially at the edge
of orgasm is breathe and breathe and
breathe because that's when
people are most likely to hold their
breath and go into these old clenching
energy curtailing patterns and so
instead we want to open up the breath
relax and open up the body and that
allows the sexual energy to move and
recirculate through the body and so not
only does a man and a woman build
stamina but they're also nourishing
themselves the breath is acting to move
and recirculate the sexual energy in the
body and so then we end up feeling
energized after sex rather than tired
after sex and again that's the question
that i said earlier if you feel
energized after sex you're doing it
right
if you feel tired after sex then there's
a way that you're leaking all of that
energy out of you through your sexual
experience and so we want to get to the
place where you have sex and you want to
go to the gym you have sex and you want
to run a marathon you have sex and you
want to clean your house from top to
bottom you know that is when you know
that you've taken that pure beautiful
life force energy and now you're wearing
it you're radiating it you are you've
disseminated it through your entire
system right and it's nourishing you
that is the goal of sex pleasure great
awesome
like but for me it's really this idea
this is your fuel source right and it's
free and abundant and you can use it any
time you like
yes and so do you feel like the more
that men practice that breathing that it
will just get easier over time basically
definitely i have had men go in a few
days from being a five-minute ejaculator
to being able to go for an hour by
really consciously practicing these
breathing techniques and i've got a
playlist on my youtube channel called
sexual mastery for men where there's
some videos on how to last longer in bed
my sexual mastery for men online course
goes into this in great detail but yeah
like really within days i mean if these
are really and they often are
long-standing patterns for people then
it can take sometimes longer it can take
a few weeks but seriously it can happen
that quickly where you can change a
lifetime
of a pattern into something where you
now have control and consciousness over
that power
i'm really going to encourage the women
listening to this to have their partners
tune in to this episode i have a largely
female audience but this is such
powerful pivotal information for both
men and women to learn and now going in
the other direction for women can you
talk about you know you talk a lot about
numb vaginas and a lot of women have
these weak numb vaginas and how that
obviously plays a huge role in the
enjoyment of sex so can you talk about
that and also let's get into jade eggs
yeah
so
yeah most women have known vaginas and
that's for a few different reasons
number one is because they don't
exercise them properly so the idea of do
your kegels which most of us have heard
over our lifetimes is actually faulty
meaning that the original
exercise that dr kegel invented in 1947
involved using a device called a kegel
perineometer inside of the vagina and so
by contracting on this device using
feedback and resistance just like the
idea of lifting weights in the gym we
would build muscle strength and he had a
90 success rate in using this exercise
in his practice to heal urinary
incontinence and then other doctors over
time adapted the exercise except they
just told women to omit the device omit
inserting anything into the vagina and
instead just flap their vaginas at
random in the wind and immediately the
success of the exercise taint you know
50 and it's been dropping ever since
right the stats are that 60 of women
have issues of urinary incontinence and
50 of women according to the yale
university school of medicine
after childbirth suffer some kind of
pelvic organ prolapse which is insane
right it's insane that that is the
normalized reality that we live in and
so lack of exercise or proper exercise
is the number one reason for that
numbness but then it's all kinds of um
trauma and internalized beliefs like
we've been talking about let's say
having a string of lovers who just come
within three minutes and feeling like
your vagina is just something to be used
for somebody else's pleasure right or
women who have a habit of putting
vaginal lubrication false lubrication
into their vagina which is then
perpetually overriding the voice of the
vagina and i encourage women not to use
lube i encourage women to cultivate that
wetness from within
whether it's physiological because even
using a jade egg which is my recommended
tool for building up pelvic floor
strength and the vaginal strength
is creating the circulation as you build
that muscle strength you improve
circulation and circulation equals
lubrication you get all that blood flow
and oxygen and fluid moving and then you
create that sentience if women have this
disconnect with their vaginas through
again through trauma or like a lack of
physicality or bad sexual experiences
then they're feeling a dissociation
right they're feeling like some women a
lot of women that i work with feel like
they don't even want to put their own
fingers into their vaginas they feel
like it's this you know really separate
almost scary foreign place and it's in
their own bodies right that's the
reinforcing that they've had over the
years and so getting back into that
connection and reviving it so that you
have this vagina that's pleasurable and
sentient and articulate right like a
nice analogy to use is this idea of
thinking about your hand right your hand
can lie there and you can touch it and
give it sensation and it's a passive
recipient of whatever is happening to it
or you can have a very active hand that
can squeeze and press and pull and
isolate all these different parts of it
one finger two fingers top bottom left
right
that is what a vagina is really meant to
be able to do to have all that kind of
awareness and articulation in it and
through using a jade egg which is i'm
what i'm all about teaching that's how
we get that is because that's the
ancient practice this has been happening
for thousands of years in other cultures
especially in daoist china
where we would actually practice this to
keep our vaginas awake and alive and be
connected to them as a power source
so i love everything you just said
especially about the natural lubrication
within your own body instead of using
like a lube which i think there's so
much confusion about that that a lot of
people women and men included don't even
know so for women you do women who are
listening here you do your work in
regards to the jade egg learning all
about it and then men when you're going
into sex like if your woman is not
naturally lubricated like
for me i feel like the generosity goes a
long way like my husband is extremely
generous so
when it's time for us and we have a very
busy life if i'm like i got all the to
do things i definitely still have that
balance of like okay i got all these
things to do and then it's like oh yeah
like let's have sex and so he knows like
i'm gonna warm her up and be extremely
generous and then that's when it flows
and it happens and no lube needed
that's beautiful and this is why i
recommend that couples have three hour
sex dates once a week you set aside
three hours that's not dinner not a
movie not a walk in the park it's just
you guys locked in a room together
to have sex and that could be a number
of things that can be massages and oral
sex and
you know all kinds of body exploration
but you're setting aside that time when
you know like you said earlier these
20-minute rushed encounters right that
you know that you've bookmarked this
sacred time that is non-negotiable
non-interruptible so you get child care
or the kids are at their
neighbor or neighbor's house or your
friend's house your grandparents house
or you get a hotel room or what an
airbnb for the night or whatever it is
but that is your time so that you have
that feeling like you never have any
pressure or rush and you can just be
with each other and let those things
unfold and if you can do that in a
shorter amount of time than great but i
encourage that as this sacred place
where you know that you always have that
and even if you had that once a week
like ideally i'd say couples are having
sex several times a week but even if you
had that once a week and then a couple
of shorter encounters throughout the
week that would be enough to really hit
these places of life-changing sex yeah
okay i have a couple questions about the
jade egg can women who are pregnant do
jade egg is that safe oh definitely it's
one of the best times to do the jade egg
practice because you want to prepare
that pelvic floor and your vagina and be
connected to them right there's a couple
issues there is that that numbness and
dissociation of a woman's giving birth
and she has that level of dissociation
how is she going to fully own her birth
process right unless she's really
connected to her vagina you're
strengthening it and so it's more
available to you to use during birth and
then it recovers much more quickly
afterwards so for many reasons plus the
way that i teach the jade egg it's
always mind body spirit and so i'm
helping people to look at those
potential emotional psychological issues
that they have that are blockages for
them and help them to clear that space
using the jade egg right which again i
believe that our birth process can be
hindered by all of these things that are
hanging in the ethers whether it's our
sexual hang-ups our relationship
problems that haven't been addressed or
past birth experiences via us or our for
mothers and that we need to do that
conscious work to really allow us to
have the most ecstatic and orgasmic
birth so the jade egg is pivotal in
doing that recommended highly
right and do you feel like because
you were talking about
women not wanting to touch their own
vaginas that you have had that
experience
do you feel like um
because i know a few women who
don't love their men going down on them
do you feel like that's related at all
i think it's like trauma related it's
that sense of dissociation and i don't
want to go there i don't want my
awareness there and it could even be
born out of past trauma right out of
sexual abuse in their history that they
haven't addressed and so it's just
holding there in this holding pattern of
don't go there don't touch this don't go
too close because it's very intimate to
have someone right up in your yoni which
is very healing actually to be cherished
and seen and adored that way and so
often the thing that we're avoiding
might be the medicine that we really
need to heal
right
[Music]
and now a few words from our sponsor who
helps make this show possible
what more perfect upgrade can you make
in your bedroom to pair with the upgrade
you'll be making in your sex life then
incredibly soft eucalyptus bedding the
bedding industry actually has a huge
impact on the environment but buffy
decided to change that their products
are made using only renewable and
recycled materials which makes them as
soft on the planet as they are in your
bed
their debut product the cloud comforter
is covered in super soft eucalyptus
fabric and filled with fluffy fiber made
from 100 recycled bottles it has over 18
000 5 star reviews and it is hands down
the best comforter i've ever slept with
the cloud comforter is ultra breathable
softer than cotton and keeps you at the
perfect temperature to feel cozy without
overheating it's hypoallergenic and
shuts out dust mold and mites for a
healthier sleep environment
plus it's machine washable which is
super cool
the average down comforter harms 12
geese but buffy's comforter is of course
cruelty free it feels softer than down
while keeping about 50 bottles out of
landfills and oceans
and eucalyptus uses 10 times less water
than cotton to grow trust me when i tell
you that this is the softest bedding
you'll ever own so use my code ellen for
twenty dollars off orders over eighty
dollars you can try a comforter in your
own bed for free if you don't love it
return it at no cost
so for people who are listening are
thinking okay i have this checklist of
things to do the work to heal and that
i'm going to be having incredible sex
right if both of us together as partners
are working on ourselves emotionally
physically doing those types of
breathing exercises jading all that
together what can people expect from
doing that kind of inner work and
healing after that what what should
what's the reward basically
everything i mean this is that you know
overlying message is that it changes
every part of your life so
you'll notice right away that your
intimate relationship gets better right
you'll actually you know when i say this
thing about having a three hour sex date
often people are like what like three
hours of sex like i totally thought that
at first when you when i first heard you
say that i was like that's ridiculous
yeah how you mean intercourse for three
hours and i'm like yeah eventually and
then you know a couple months go by of
people really committing to that work
and they're like yeah we had actual
intercourse for three hours
and didn't even notice the time went by
like that so your relationship gets
better because you're clearing that
space right you're clearing all of that
debris i call it relationship feng shui
and all of that stuff that's been
lingering and creating problems for you
and so you clear that out your intimate
connection gets so much better you want
to have sex with each other you feel
more close and connected you become each
other's fuel source right this is where
you go to recharge and then that starts
to expand out into the rest of your life
where you feel you have more energy
more confidence you don't give a [ __ ]
anymore that's one of the big thresholds
especially for women because women are
really kind of conditioned to be people
pleasers and subservient is that women
don't give a [ __ ] anymore what people
think about them right they put their
ideas and their opinions out into the
world they do what they want to do they
dress how they want to dress and they
don't care what other people think of
them they're not trying not to care they
just don't care
people will notice often in their jobs
right because your sexual energy is the
pure expression of your very authentic
nature and when you're inhabiting it
everything in your life starts to then
come into more true alignment with your
true self right so let's say you were
working a job that you didn't
it was more of a pay the bills kind of
job right not an expression of your
individual dharma your gifts to give as
an as a person then people often end up
quitting those jobs just organically and
then gravitating towards things that are
more of a vital expression of their true
nature and that just happens right again
they're not trying really hard to do
these things it just bubbles out of them
people's children start to where maybe
they were acting out before because
they're tuning into all of these
unresolved issues that are hovering
under the surface with the couple
and now that the couple becomes this
solid unified core is that that then
flows out to their family and their
children their children feel more
supported their children feel more
contained and so they start to act with
more love and they don't act out if they
were having behavioral issues before
those kind of fade away because the
children are now feeling this incredible
strength and support and unity from the
core of them which is their parents
right and the parents radiate more love
and joy and patience as well which
obviously the children tune into is in
addition to that people's bodies change
people magically just lose weight that
seems to evaporate off of them because
they've been orgasming it away
you know so orgasm is this incredible
metaphysical tool physical yes all of
the amazing neurotransmitters and
hormones that get released through
orgasm and more increased sexual
activity help with all of that with your
mood and your body weight your energy
levels but they also
help you to lose weight like i've had
clients who just had this extra 10 or 15
pounds on them that they had dieted they
had nutrition and they had exercised
away trying to get rid of and then they
started to have amazing sex and it just
fell away because the weight the excess
baggage the excess weight they were now
burning and
you know alchemizing through sex and
dealing with that and i often say that
you can save thousands of hours and
thousands of dollars on therapy by
having really deep amazing epic orgasms
it will burn through all of that stuff
in ways that you never dreamed possible
so people start to see the results even
in money you know sex and creativity and
money are all second chakra issues and
so people start to then as i say channel
that sexual energy out into the world
they become more creative and they end
up generating more cash because it
starts to fall into their lap because
their lap is what attracted it
so
as they start to give their true gifts
to the world the universe reciprocates
and gives back to them so all of these
things are sourced from your sexual
connection and these are areas that we
might never have thought would be
connected right made no relationship
between our cash flow and the you know
our level of connectedness as a couple
but it's true i've seen it over and over
and over again people going from
kind of a you know famine poverty place
in their lives and their financial
situation and then they really work on
their relationship and suddenly they're
attracting all of this abundance in
every possible way not just with dollars
but with opportunities and so that's
again tuning into this life force energy
of the universe that it can seem hard to
really fathom because of all the lies
that we've been told about sexuality all
the misinformation all the taboo all the
shame that's layered on top of that when
really it's almost not even it's not a
moral thing it's just like this is your
life force power and when you learn how
to use it yes you create from that place
and all of these incredible things
happen in your life
yes i love how you explain that it
bleeds into every every facet in your
life
and
i know that's been my personal
experience within our own relationship
and so much of is it so much of it is
the mindset
of abundance and so when you have that
abundance in your life with your sex
life with your partner
your overall relationship will be better
and then you will start seeing the world
in a more positive way and then that's
that has a huge impact i know that from
personal experience like just a few days
ago andrew or my husband was starting to
be snappy at me and we were just kind of
snappy at each other and i'm like oh we
have not had sex in a week we need to
make this make a priority and figure
this out and sure enough when we just
like really surrender to each other give
each other everything that we need
emotionally
through our private time alone together
and make that a priority like our
relationship flourishes and the family
life flourishes because we're all just
happier and more joyful
i love that and i love that you had that
realization like oh we haven't had sex
in a little while we need to get back in
there and recharge right and generate
that power source and then yes it flows
out into everything so i love that you
had that inclination like oh that is the
issue yeah
right well that was partly from what
you've said too a lot of the things that
we've read it's like you know if your
partner's being cranky maybe they need
to be [ __ ] yes
that's so funny okay sorry
it's just so funny that we're talking
about this over the internet i'm still
tripping about it
but can we get
um into cervical orgasms what you call
the queen of orgasms i think a lot of
women don't have the tools or maybe like
okay they're in it with they've learned
a lot from you and they're growing a lot
in their um their psychology and
changing and doing the work with jade
eggs and stuff but like maybe still
haven't gotten there so what advice do
you have any details you can give to
like help
women or help men help women reach that
like deep cervical orgasms
right so in my work i'm all about the
vagina i say that the good stuff the
better more life-changing
power
orgasms are in the vagina and so you
know the deeper you go the deeper you go
the clitoral orgasms are great as a
warm-up as an appetizer but then the
deeper more nourishing really
life-changing orgasms are in the vagina
so we have the g-spot and then the
cervix which yes i call the queen of
female orgasms and in taoist reflexology
because they map out reflexology points
in the vagina as well they look at the
cervix as being the heart point and even
in western medicine the vagus nerve goes
up from the cervix the vagus nerve which
is thought to be the most spiritual
nerve in the body
up all the way through the heart into
the crown chakra right and so having
these cervical orgasms taps us into the
heart but also into this full spiritual
universal rebirthing energy and that's
why i say these are like the best good
[ __ ] medicine for women women have this
incredible
power tool at their disposal which is
their cervixes and you know also to know
that if a woman no longer has a cervix
she can still have cervical orgasms she
can tune into that energy as a phantom
limb and still get to these amazing
places so all of the vaginal orgasms so
g-spot ejaculating or squirting orgasms
and cervical orgasms all have one major
factor in common which is this idea of
surrender and opening and letting go and
so if you have any kind of unresolved
issue with your partner any kind of
unresolved issue with yourself it's
going to be very difficult to get there
and so as an example let's say that you
had an argument with your partner over
breakfast time and you never really
cleared it right you're still kind of
holding it or you just tried to put it
aside but really there's some stuff that
you would have liked to have said and to
gotten to have dealt with but you know
and so you go to have sex that night and
maybe he's not that hard and you're not
very wet and you have sex anyway you use
some lube you know you do some extra
things to make it work and then you
don't have your orgasm well
you know if you build it they will come
you didn't build it
you didn't do the preliminary work to
clear that space and i guarantee that if
you had cleared that argument and if you
didn't have years worth of those things
that needed clearing you would much more
easily get to that place and that's the
other thing there could be decades or
years worth of stuff that people have
like i said before swept under the
carpet and never dealt with that is
going to impact whether you can get to
these deeper states of orgasm
in a really big way plus this whole idea
of having a numb vagina and so practices
like using the jade egg yoni massage is
another beautiful way to really explore
do vaginal reconnaissance open up into
the vagina and de-numb the vagina and so
i have a couple of great videos on my
youtube channel on yoni massage and
[ __ ] shiatsu and i go into it in detail
in my coming together salon in vaginal
kung fu like a step-by-step process of
how to do it but there's beginner guides
in my youtube channel and that's a
really great way to get to know your own
vagina and your partner to get to know
your vagina and help that de-numbing
process so there's all these
multi-faceted steps that you can take to
open up that space because you want to
feel like you know your vagina inside
and out and that if there's any of your
own personal traumas that you haven't
dealt with like sexual abuse or assault
or even these beliefs that we've been
talking about all of that stuff will
play into it so now you're getting a bit
of a picture painted of how much work it
might actually take so when people go to
look some people i'll just say to them
look i guarantee that every woman can
have g-spot orgasms and cervical orgasms
and some women will go home that very
night and have their first g-spot orgasm
just because i told them they could
right they bought into this narrative
that only some women can don't feel bad
if you can't you know which i say is
total bs every woman can they go and
they do for some women they might have
more
baggage right more of these traumas and
blockages that need to be cleared before
their body is like okay you've helped me
you've healed me you've cleared the
space there you go if you build it they
will come so this is the kind of stuff
that's all through my salons of this
inner work both physical with the vagina
jade egg yoni massage all of that kind
of stuff and then energetic and inner
psyche psychological spiritual work to
clear space it's really what it's all
about is feng shui sexual feng shui yeah
that's so beautiful especially because
it does it's not only just for when
you're in bed with your partner it
affects all facets of your life
so
that's incredible so i have a question
about keeping the simmer can you
elaborate a little bit i've heard you
talk about it and it's fascinating about
the importance for women but i think men
too but especially women to keep that
simmer throughout the day and what is it
that keeps a simmer can you explain that
and how do you get there where like
you're doing the dishes and your partner
walks by and brushes you know brushes up
against you and it turns you on or
you're feeling that simmer with them
what what keeps that and how do you get
there right
so the idea of the sexual simmer is that
there's always this hum this electricity
between you so think about when you're
actually feeling attracted to your
partner or maybe you it's the prelude to
you going off to the bedroom what's that
energy that palpable energy between you
well i'm saying that you live with that
all the time to some degree
right and instead of like everything
going from a zero to a ten and back to a
zero again you actually exist at a seven
or eight this perpetual simmer and so
part of that is all of the stuff that
i've just described is this open
communication
ongoing clearing of your blocks between
you in within yourself as an individual
and then practicing with your partner
and so that could just be like like you
the example you gave this loving sensual
touch throughout the day so you walk
past them you might give their butt a
squeeze you know you give them a kiss
but it's not just a like a perfunctory
pack you have a you know short little 10
second makeout session in the kitchen
and great if your kids see that's
awesome if your kids see because they
need to know that their parents are
really into each other it's one of the
most reassuring things that you can show
them is that their parents not only love
each other but they love making love to
each other
that actually builds strength and trust
in your in your children it's one of the
most powerful gifts that you can give
them so text messages giving them like
either loving and adoring text messages
or a flirtatious text message photo if
you want to send it all of these things
you're keeping that energy lifted right
keeping it alive between you so then
when you go to have sex boom you're
already nearly there right you live in
that state and that might seem hard for
people because maybe in our instant
gratification kind of society thinking
like oh i have a tinge of arousal i
should go bust out an orgasm like
there's this pattern of like feeling
that and then wanting to nullify it
right to go back to that zero place and
i'm like no you actually start to train
yourself to live in that seven or eight
and that's when you become this really
sensual you know
radiant um
being that you're living in that energy
all the time and that is normal right
that's what i consider to be normal and
the idea that we're dissociated with
that energy might have become normalized
but it's not normal normal is living in
bliss all the time
yeah i was actually going to say that
because i know some women this isn't for
every woman i know that you know
different personalities and what they
crave for their love languages are
different but for a lot of women you
know they might desire that type of
affection throughout the day like
brushing up against or give me a mini
makeout session or send me a like sexy
text type thing but then some men might
be like yeah but when i do that then i
want to have sex and i know we can't
have sex right that moment so like i
can't do that at all but you're like you
need to build up your your stamina so
that you can handle it and keep the
simmer with your partner which is
perfect perfectly said
that's really the like the tantric way
and philosophy is that you build your
capacity for more and more pleasure
right so like what you said that cop out
of oh it might be too much for me
[ __ ] deal with it you know
like build it and learn to live there
right you're like increasing your
threshold of pleasure and living and
existing in that place so if normally
you know a five out of ten is where a
lot of people exist or lower right um
you move that to a seven to an eight to
a nine to a [ __ ] 15 out of ten is
where you start to live in terms of
pleasure and flow and bliss in your life
and you can everyone can right but this
is the the process yes it's work and
play to get there but it's possible for
everyone
yeah all the stuff that you're saying
actually kind of makes me think of
people men or women who have had sexual
trauma and how they might be told
there's nothing you can do about it
you're going to experience this trauma
and like not be able to have maybe
open-hearted sex your whole life when
really you're talking about true inner
healing so that you can experience this
next level
like orgasmic open-hearted type of sex
and it's a really beautiful concept the
idea of like truly healing inside from
whatever the traumas be whether it's
sexual trauma or just trauma based on
what you've been told about sex and
relationships and
yeah it just makes me think of it all
together all tied in
i agree fully and
it is like you know that's one of the
big
i don't know in western medicine there's
a lot of very doomsday diagnoses right
like we have no cure for that we don't
know how you got it we don't know how to
fix it but you'll just have it forever
and maybe if you take these pills
forever it'll kind of be moderately you
know mitigated right like it's a really
yeah
um i don't but put any
stock in that at all right i believe
that there's a solution for everything
and that we can find it and there's a
natural solution for everything so
that's my philosophy and that as above
so below meaning if we go inside and do
that deeper emotional psycho-spiritual
work that filters then down into the
physical body and can heal anything in
the physical body yeah
so i have a question that i've been
wanting to ask you um which is when it
goes back to that first thing i said
where if i could sit down and have a
conversation with you this is what i
would ask you is what about women who
recently gave birth or they're
breastfeeding and the libido is just
naturally lower what's your advice to
them or what are your thoughts on that
well let's correct that phrase libido is
naturally lower for one because i think
that's something that people buy into
again it's something that might be
normalized but is it really normal and
there's a lot of you know answers to
that question i just did an interview
with someone who was eight months
pregnant when she found my work and she
just it just you know fired up in her
she's like i don't care if this maybe
maybe for most people would not be the
right timing to do this work she's like
we're in right to her partner and so she
just threw herself into it she gave
birth early even like so it was like a
week or two later she gave birth and
then they were within days she was
having intercourse with her partner like
she just decided that yeah exactly you
know this is how it's going to be and
i'm not going to fall prey to these
ideas and you know kind of spells cast
upon women saying that this is a really
you know challenging time for them and
so she took charge she became cause
rather than effect in that situation she
told a story of how one week after
giving birth she baked a hundred
cinnamon buns she like started this
whole baking business and like had the
most impetus to do it right after giving
birth and she really um accredits her
sex life like she says that even with
her partner like when they've stayed up
all night with the baby they have sex
because that they know is the thing
that's going to give them energy to fuel
their day rather than thinking oh we're
tired we'll go to sleep we you know
let's not have sex right now they do the
opposite and they've trained themselves
to do that
wow that's actually that was in that's
interesting when it comes to the thing
about at night when you're up all night
with your baby let's just have sex and
make it a beautiful experience
like you know take care of the baby and
you know the baby's gonna be up in an
hour or whatever like
that is actually pretty cool because i i
fully believe in the power of the mind i
know you and i are both on the same page
with that and i think the mind is
incredibly powerful and like you said it
is it is told over and over again your
libido is lower right after you give
birth and when you're breastfeeding and
everything like that but i agree with
you that the mind is that powerful that
if you really believe in something you
will make it as incred an incredible
experience of what it's really what you
make it i think that as far as like
health as well like if what you're
eating if you truly and your
subconscious believe it's healthy for
you
you're gonna experience health benefits
as opposed to if you're eating something
that like maybe you're told it's healthy
for you but like your subconscious is
like i don't think this is actually
healthy for me you're gonna experience
some maybe less than subpar health so
your mind is so powerful so that's
really interesting about the libido and
breastfeeding and all of that and i
think like what you make a priority
really really affects whatever's a
priority for you really makes a
difference
well it's also it's really embodying
that idea that your sex life is your
power source right if you're having a
baby like you need each other you need
each other as an energy source to plug
into you need that more than ever and
often you know if a couple is having any
kind of challenges and then they have
their birth and especially if there's
any issues in the birth that's going to
drive them further apart right that's
going to separate them where i try to
encourage couples like i have a whole
program because of that called sexy mama
that's about bringing couples together
so that they're a solid unit prior to
the birth they have much more chance of
having a pleasurable even orgasmic birth
and then they're even closer after the
birth rather than the opposite of what
typically happens right because i think
that birth trauma is a massive issue
why a couple you know and because
there's no space to really acknowledge
birth trauma and the the atrocities of
it is that people separate and
dissociate because of that right and
that's why we see couples separate
not physically like divorce but i mean
energetically separate after birth
rather than come together is because
often so many births are rife with
trauma right rather than being a
peaceful loving entry into the world and
that we're not training ourselves to go
to each other for that power source
right that's the main thing that i'm
always trying to drive home with people
is that you go to recharge with each
other and that is the most powerful
rejuvenation source that you have and so
you like i said like the couple they're
up all night and instead of like passing
out they're like we need to make love
now
to have energy to get through this day
together
yes oh my gosh and everything you just
said about
that deep desire to want to reconnect
with your partner and just recharge it
makes me think about how you talk a lot
about how we should be loving our
partner's genitalia and i know that
there are some women who don't like love
or enjoy going down on their man so can
you elaborate on that on why we should
love our partner's genitalia and how to
help encourage that
well look our genitalia really are the
essence of who we are right that is the
core of us packaged up in that space and
so i do i really encourage people to
love up their partner's genitals and so
many people have insecurities about
their partners their genitals in general
like especially men right their [ __ ]
size their performance and so i'm always
encouraging women to love their partners
[ __ ] and to show slather it with
affection every way that you can you
know as you're walking by it you just
give it a little stroke and a little
hello as much time as you can spend with
it and i over the years have fallen in
love with my partner's [ __ ] and i end
up having two relationships one with the
partner and one with their genitalia and
i miss them both when they're not around
so
this is one of the most beautiful gifts
that we can give our partners is to
really help them to own their genitals
and love their genitals right and remove
any kind of shame or embarrassment or
insecurity it's one of the massive
things we can do to heal and regenerate
on that level is being seen right truly
being seen and cherished and adored and
i over the years have had partners whose
[ __ ] then grow because i have given
them so much love that they actually
gain an inch in length and width because
they've been loved up so much they can
truly own themselves and grow into their
full potential
yeah i think i think the way that you
worded that about like truly loving your
partner for everything that they are
it makes so much sense and the the mind
uh shift within that based on a lot of
the maybe the things we've been told
about sex and about our partner versus
like tuning in to really loving who they
are and their essence and like that will
just
over like just overflow that love for
their genitalia as well and that really
helps you to open up when you're in the
bedroom as well because you truly feel
seen and loved and like cherished it's
really powerful information
yeah there's no hiding right and all the
places where we're hiding i like to call
it demon hunting right like you go
looking for those places and then
illuminate them bring them all into the
light and you heal each other that's one
of the most beautiful gifts that you
give it's all the places where you have
darkness and fear and embarrassment and
past hurts you open up those places and
you love them back up to this
full potential of who we are
yeah
so can we shift a little bit and talk
about women who are single like we've
talked a lot about gourmet sex with your
partner and pleasure um let's elaborate
elaborate a little bit and can you share
a little bit about like women who are
single and the pleasure that they
can experience or what you what you
suggest and advice yeah look i've had
some of my most well [ __ ] periods of
my life when i've been single because i
committed to a regular self-pleasuring
practice a regular yoni egg practice
and yoni massage so the tools that i've
already talked about using the jdag
yoni massage that you can do on yourself
and then regular self pleasure right
it's keeping that engine revved up so
that that same power source that i've
been talking about all along it's
available to us whether we're in
partnership where yes it gets amplified
tenfold but you still have access to
that and i've you know women that i've
worked with and myself have had epic
results in
tuning into that energy and then
channeling it out into the world even as
a single person so one of the best
things that i can recommend is well
those top three tools using a jade egg
doing yoni massage as that as that
vaginal self reconnaissance and then
self pleasuring and i would say to kick
it off if you've been in let's say a dry
spell is commit to a 30 day challenge
and so every day for the next 30 days
you're going to be self pleasuring and
this is the kind of stuff where i
actually have a technique that i use
called meditate masturbate create that
really fits for self pleasuring so the
idea is that you spend about you know
even a few minutes in meditation and i
use mantras for meditation so any kind
of charged word one of my favorite ones
is called hue it's pronounced hu or
and you chant that for a few minutes and
then you self pleasure so anywhere from
i would recommend at least 15 minutes to
30 even 45 minutes of self-pleasuring
incorporating that deep breathing that i
was talking about and then go do
something the create part is then being
aware that you have this powerful life
force energy and either go do something
that's
typically creative like writing drawing
painting but gardening playing with your
children doing some kind of work project
where you're aware
of funneling all of that energy into
that project
yes okay cool i'm so glad that you
touched on that because i think a lot of
times maybe people can be listening to
this conversation and go well this
doesn't apply to me because i'm single
right now but the way that you explain
it and how this really is truly part of
our innate power within us and to
harness it i think that's really
beautiful and definitely not something
that i was taught growing up at all no
it's really the opposite where
masturbation is really shameful and
somebody gets caught masturbating right
which can be early imprinting of that
sexual repression for sure
yeah
okay so can you also talk a little bit
about conscious monogamy i know that
you've talked a lot about that um on
your channel can you elaborate what are
your thoughts on it what does it mean
conscious monogamy well my assertion is
that 99.9
of people actually aren't monogamous
they might call themselves monogamous
and maybe they're not having sex with
other people maybe they are but they
just don't tell each other but they're
really not truly consciously monogamous
and my definition of that is that it's
when you pour
all of your emotional and sexual
energies and into your partner right
you're fully open emotionally you're not
holding back you're not playing little
defensive games and having barriers that
you hide behind you're fully exposed and
open and the same thing sexually you're
fully in abandonment and surrender
all your walls are down hardly anybody
has that right and so what most people
are saying when they say oh monogamy
doesn't work you're actually saying that
shitty relationships don't work because
most people just have really crappy
relationships where they're lying to
each other they're not sexually really
open to each other they're playing these
games of you know sins of omission and
not telling the truth and not really
asking for and getting what they want
and they're calling that a relationship
and they're calling that monogamy but
really like i said it's just a bad
relationship so the amount of people who
have what i actually describe as
conscious monogamy are very few most of
them come out of my work because i teach
them all these practices of how to
actually cultivate that in their
intimate lives and then yes they have
that level of full gourmet sex heart
open genitals open fully giving to each
other and in those situations they have
no desire for other people right that
desire for other people when it's
usually hidden behind you know we're so
liberated we're so modern this is what
humans were meant to be like i i know i
debate that because when i work with
couples even if they've been in that
headspace when we peel back the layers
and we figure out like what are the
decisions that often cause them to go in
that direction something that wasn't
happening in the relationship and then
that's what i work on is well how do we
make the relationship its best right and
one of the
arguments that people will use is well
you know are we really meant to be
having sex with the same person our
whole lives and i say well
if you're committed to growth and
evolution you aren't having sex with the
same person your partner is constantly
changing and evolving into new and
better versions of themselves and so are
you however if you're committed to
stagnation and you're committed to being
the same person for the rest of your
life then yeah you are having sex with
that same person and i could see how
that could be dull and boring which
again is really just that same idea of
being in a crappy relationship oh my
gosh everything you just said is so on
point i so resonate with everything you
said i feel more deeply in love with my
husband
every year and we've been together since
we're 15 and 16 years old and we are
completely different people
than we were when we were in high school
and i think about how
like you said if you're committed to
evolving and growing and being open to
change it really does deepen your desire
for that person because you see the
goodness of them you see their growth
and it's very attractive
when you're with someone who is not
wanting to grow or change it's very
depressing
because then you kind of feel stagnant
you feel it's harder for you to grow and
you're like just stuck in this this
awful place
and that's why open communication and
openness honesty and trust is so huge
and integral and like a beautiful like
love-filled relationship and it all ties
together everything you're saying
because the more love that you're
deepening together the better your sex
is and the better your relationship is
yeah well
all of those things and a commitment to
growth like the idea that yes we're
always looking at how to become the best
versions of ourselves and how to make
the best version of our relationship
where i think most people maybe
unknowingly are committed to stagnation
right like oh you know
i don't know it's hard for me to fathom
i often say there's two types of people
in the world people who are committed to
growth and becoming better in their
lives and themselves and people who
aren't right and the kinds of work that
i'm talking about is like both people
really do need to be on that path and
one person can be on that path and
invite the other person and then they
can just focus on their own work and
sometimes the other person comes along
and sometimes they don't but ultimately
to reach all of these epic places i'm
talking about both people need to be on
that journey yeah and i think it's like
such a beautiful symbiotic relationship
because my husband brings things out of
me it brings things to light that i need
to grow in and i'll do the same thing
for him and while it might be hard and
frustrating at first and you're like i
don't want to change or i can't change
or like i'm fine leave me alone but when
you're willing to just open up and
realize hey this is where i need to grow
because we all have our different things
that we're better at we help each other
grow and ah it's so beautiful it's such
a beautiful part of relationships and i
love the way you describe that how we're
different people if we're committed to
change and you really can deepen your
love for that partner and then you don't
like you you don't you're not going to
desire other other people in other
relationships because you're just so
committed and in love with your growth
together
right and that depth builds over time
and you know there's this whole idea
that our intimate relationships are
meant to trigger each other on deep
levels and bring up old wounds because
we're in that really intimate space with
each other and then a conscious
relationship will go okay great we look
at these triggers as they come up and we
as i said illuminate them and transform
them and heal and grow and evolve
through them where in a less conscious
relationship people like oh my god
another problem oh there's always
problems you know
and then they kind of give up on the
relationship or never think they should
put any energy into it or just you know
numb it out right over time where like i
said that giant pile of debris just gets
bigger and bigger to the point where
people
are so disconnected from each other that
they either leave the relationship or
they stay in it and then they have other
partners or whatever else they do to
cope with that level of disconnect
between the couple
wow yeah this is such pivotal
information such vital information all
tied in together so i just have a couple
more questions for you one of them being
how did this become your passion and how
does this become your business because
there's other sex experts out there but
i haven't found any other ones that are
like you
ah thanks ellen well look it's been a
very organic process like as i was
growing up i had this awareness of my
sexual energy and as this portal like
my intuitive sense was it was like this
opening this energetic portal to other
states of consciousness and awareness
and so i always had this kind of
spiritual
association with it even though that
didn't come from anywhere in my life it
didn't come from my family it didn't
from the from the culture at large it
was somehow this innate knowing and then
i had some really powerful epic
initial sexual experiences like cervical
orgasms early on in my sex life and
then discovered tantra and taoism and
found okay look there's these cultures
and these systems of philosophy that
really are a better reflection of my
intuitive journey than anything that
i've seen in western culture right or
worldwide culture that defines what sex
is or describes what it can be
and so i really followed that and then
mostly but my own exploration and
journey and then all of that combined
with
always being interested in how do we
change how do we grow how do we
self-actualize and become the best
versions of ourselves so even as a
teenager i was studying meditation
philosophy looking at nutrition
alternative healing herbs homeopathy
exercise all of this stuff transpersonal
psychology i was just self-educating i
was hungry for all this information
because again obsessed like how do we
evolve how do we grow how do we
transform and then to me my sexual
experiences were really like some of the
most powerful things that i would emerge
out of one of these cataclysmic
encounters and feel reborn feel like i
was the better more like authentic
powerful version of myself and so sex
was always a tool for me like a growth
tool for me and then eventually i just
put all of that stuff together
to create my holistic sex and
relationship coaching and no one really
talked about it the way that i did until
i came along because before i came along
it was really like clinical
lab coat
sterile view of biochemistry sex or kind
of like this cosmo giggly juvenile oh
did you see his willy
like kind of childish you know view of
sex and nothing in between that was like
sexy sex of you know sex is empowering
and beautiful and healthy and holistic
and we can still have a voracious sex
drive but be a fully
um you know competent
successful powerful person like blending
all that middle ground together and so
that's just it just
you know and plus i really do practice
what i preach like my creative energy
comes from my vagina and so as much as i
think of myself as a teacher and a
healer i'm a creator and so i have so
much fun coming up with all these
different ideas of how to promote these
concepts right so rather than like let's
say for for vaginal strength you know
doing interviews of like well women will
pee their pants less if they do these
exercises i'm out there lifting objects
indigenous to various regions all over
the world with the hashtag things i left
with my vagina right lifting chandeliers
and mangoes and coconuts all over the
planet and so that and then that stuff
goes viral and people get excited about
it but i'm using these playful creative
fun ways to educate about serious topics
but i'm doing it in ways that turn me on
right that stuff it gives me so much
pleasure and joy and i get turned on and
that's my litmus test if i get turned on
it usually turns on or wakes up other
people
oh totally when you say certain things
the way you say things my husband and i
read your weekly emails and we're like
oh my gosh yes like even just the the
part about loving your partner's
genitalia then we go into the bedroom
like yes what what was this veil over
my head like my face that like maybe
it's not that great when really it's
actually incredible and the way that you
can cherish each other like like just
just even just reading words and
learning that information is very sexy
for people and it really helps people
get into the right into the right
mindset to go after go after it
i love it i'm glad to hear that yeah so
lastly you have a course that's
relaunching soon called vaginal kung fu
can you tell us about that and when does
it relaunch for people who are sitting
here they're listening and they're like
okay i'm ready i'm ready to like change
my life change and just like
increase intimacy and love and
connection in my bed and in my life and
they're like where do i begin you
definitely need to get her course please
talk about it well it all starts in your
vagina so hence vaginal kung fu the art
and
practice of power from your vagina so
that's my signature course where i teach
people how to use the jade ioni egg and
so it's got a series of physical
exercises guided mp3s as well as guided
visualizations and meditations but then
it encompasses the whole sexual being so
we do everything from breast massage to
all kinds of modalities for healing
block clearing as we've been talking
about to make your vagina your power
source right to make that connection
bring it back to de-numb it so then your
vagina becomes your compass it becomes
your guide in life right your mover and
your shaker and your orgasm giver
so that it's everything you're fully
reconnected and you embody that sensual
power and energy in everything you do so
like all of my work it's many dimensions
so physical with the exercises emotional
psychological spiritual energetic so
that we have that whole person healing
because in my experience when you do
whole person healing you have permanent
results and not just short-term fixes
and so that's the name of the game so
the course starts it opens for
registration on the 19th of january and
then it's open for a couple of weeks and
then we start early february
perfect oh well this is perfect timing
because this is right when this course
or this episode will be coming out and
for everyone listening either consider
getting the course or just go into her
youtube channel subscribe to her email
list because i promise you
it is life-changing stuff and just
consistently start listening to this
information on your podcast you have a
podcast correct right you still post
that consistently yes so my orgasmic
enlightenment podcast actually there's
an episode just put out there called
five techniques to create a super [ __ ]
along these lines
and it's called orgasmic enlightenment
and then i also on my youtube channel i
put out educational videos as well so
i'm always putting out tons of free
content i have all my online courses
that are available like the one you just
mentioned these are my 8 to 10 week
classes that run throughout the year but
i also put out a ton of free content for
people to take advantage of and i
recommend that you do
yeah that's perfect well i really hope
everyone listening or watching today
gained so much inspiration from this
conversation i know i did i can't wait
for my husband to get home that's for
sure
love it ellen i know right well i feel
like that's pretty good i covered a lot
of what i wanted to ask you and i'm just
so thankful i got to have this
conversation with you and i cannot wait
to share it with the world
so thank you so much for being here
thank you for having me this was a
delightful conversation it really was
okay cool well we are signing off now
thanks everyone for watching see you
next time
[Music]
you